(choking)
(upbeat music)
- My mom would never let me have candy
because I'm an athlete,
which means I'm supposed
to be having healthy stuff.
- I've never had candy because my mom,
sometimes she's a little
bit of a control freak.
- Because my parents think
I'm gonna get cavities.
- Probably because I
don't like them, honestly.
Yeah, I hate fruit.
Anything fruit flavored I won't go near.
- This could be my chance to
have as much candy as I want.
- Hot Tamales.
Fierce cinnamon?
- I just need to do an inspection.
- Oh, gosh, ah, ugh!
- This is hot.
- The first one I tried
just tastes like sugar,
but it's not terrible.
- Red Vines.
Looks like it's like a Christmas-y thing.
- It feels a little squishy.
- Ugh.
- You don't like it?
- No.
- Flavored rubber, but I kinda like it.
- Butteryfinger by Nestle.
- Crispety, crunchety peanut-buttery.
- No artificial flavors or colors.
I don't believe it.
- Oh, yeah, these are good.
Tastes like a peanut crunch.
- It does make me more
of a peanut butter fan.
- Fun Dip.
Cherry yum diddly dip.
- For this little packet,
it says there's 45 calories.
I have a hard time believing that.
- It's really good, though!
- When I eat it, it feels
like I'm eating chalk.
- Using something that's sugar
and you're dipping it in sugar,
so it's just double the amount of fat.
- Toxic Waste!
And kids eat this for pleasure?
Dude, I can smell it from here.
(dramatic drum roll)
("Moonlight Sonata" by Beethoven)
(disgusted yelling)
(upbeat music)
(gasping)
- No fun?
- No.
- I feel like I took skin off my tongue.
(upbeat jazz music)
- I'm more hyper.
- I'm starting to see, like,
little hairs in the air.
Try and catch them.
- Butterfingers was really
crunchy and delicious.
- I didn't like the licorice.
- Some of it was good, some of it wasn't,
but I think it was not terrible.
(upbeat jazz music)